I understand that and I I didn't realize
that until I was there and then I
realized he was trans GS people's friend
bro okay trains a lot of guys I would
fly up to Montreal just to train with
him okay I didn't know that okay take it
easy I see yes so don't sit down you
know my friend was my road coach to see
him through some [ __ ] okay my Road coach
though he kind of went as I was doing as
I was pushing the sled he was like [ __ ]
and I go what he goes [ __ ] him in shape
and I go oh yeah dude he goes and he
goes and I go what he goes never mind I
go what he goes would you ever want to
start fighting I go no dude I don't that
never I can't I can't
guys either well he's I threatened Chris
like I delete again yeah so I'm on I'm
sitting on the you know the wall the
side of the wall and there's this guy
who's protecting the comedian's kind of
a strong looking dude the one thing I
can't take is a bully yeah I'm gonna
fight yeah I I can't I can't so I'm
sitting on the wall and he and I go if
he does it I'm like hard you know you've
been with me where my heart is light no
no no I'm gonna no he was heckling Chris
and then Chris was walking and I saw him
mark Chris and I go if he does anything
to Chris I'm gonna fight I said that to
some I think it was somebody was next to
me and I my heart starts beating Obama
we're gonna go now I'm gonna go I'm
gonna fight this got a knock I'm gonna
punch him right now do you like does
your brain in that moment go okay this /
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna I don't know
I don't know I just know her I just know
that it's worth all the jail time and
the risk I'm going I'm going
because I saw him he gets in Chris's
face of his put like that and you can
ask Chris what I did after lord chris do
huh
de Christo
Chris acts completely inconvenienced he
doesn't get mad the way I do yeah Chris
is like ah dude whatever come on the guy
the guys and he's a tough-looking guy
yeah but um that's it so now he tries to
come has me and I get now I get in it's
that small space and I'm I'm moving my
shoulders I'm going right on the side
asking I'm doomed
the one thing to move on me because I
want to show him what I'm gonna do cuz I
turn my body I'm going imagine if I let
my fist go on I'm doing this right in
front of him Chris is like and then I
thought the bachelor was his friend and
I look at the bouncer who's this big and
I'm so angry go and do it if you're
gonna try to protect him I'll cut
through you like a [ __ ] knife to a
hot butter so I'm gonna beat you up
afterwards is that your friend I was so
angry I'm doing this he goes like this
he he he looks at me he goes you UFC UFC
I go no I'm gonna [ __ ] you I'm losing my
mind arm and he goes he goes he goes
this is my spot this is my spot and
you're doing that to my friend so now
we're in a world of trouble cuz you're
not going anywhere it's no way that's
how crazy at the time I got an a street
fight with a bunch of [ __ ] dudes in
Hoboken New Jersey
I don't think so now I'm walking with my
girl Kelly and shout out to Kelly Kelly
and hausky chubowski Leto nope nope but
she's Slater nope nope no Kelly Slater
the surfer who I was back when she was a
girl and I'm in Hoboken New Jersey
walking after dinner and three young
ruffians let's call him
they were probably I was 23 and they
were 18 maybe even 17 maybe 14 nope nope
but they were they were older I'll tell
you why I know that so the guy goes the
guy goes now [ __ ] your girl and I think
I go mmm can't have that wait we guys
just walking by yeah in this red mouth
[ __ ] yo girl I stop and I turn
I know do [ __ ] your girl for me again
let me forget that go back the story of
those beautiful Ricans were a chirpin I
think they might have imported reading
them but you know but then again you
know there could be a mix of things but
anyway so by the way they're kids and
and I come back I turn around and I go
what did you say about my girl and he
goes I won't say anybody girl man he's
looking down he goes yes I go alright
and I walk in he goes but I'll [ __ ] your
girl now I turn back around and I go
you're talking to me now
and he goes whatever shoes move on move
on shoes on shoes I had a pair of black
shoes and back then I would always wear
black shoes and I preferred with a
steel-toed boot steel toe and a soles I
could get some traction on they know the
route also I could kick I was taekwondo
guy remember ok wrestlers - ok I know
you laugh but this is my street friends
you go much well dude I'm not big see
what happens is I'm cute dog you
understand I'm a hothead because what he
told you shoes they thought these black
boots yeah they were shoes they weren't
even boots of armor their shoes so
anyway I think they were like they were
like Doc Martens but not Doc Martens
because I didn't like Doc Martens cuz
skinhead words time man bla bla so
anyway so uh he calls me shoes and then
I kicked him like a tease him I tried to
kick him in the face throw hot head man
I kind of miss shoes babes hi yeah well
there no no cuz you're saying I'm gonna
[ __ ] your girl I know but that's a I'm
tried to move on shoes and then and then
I I kicked I knew he was [ __ ] with me
cuz he was talking my girl and I kicked
him in the face I didn't quite hit him
in the face I think I hit him in the
shoulder long story short he jumps on me
and grabs me around the waist and now
I'm punching him in the head can't hurt
him yeah I can't hurt him nolan Ryan's
though yeah but I'm not hurting him I'm
hitting him and and then his two buddies
are circling me but they're not hitting
in weird one kid tries to hit me I kind
of duck it's very awkward no
stuff here okay I think a [ __ ] fest it's
a [ __ ] fest to Sesame Street
now a woman a girl who's one of their
friends come over to us I remember to
never forget her she goes how old are
you how old do you sir as I'm beating
these kids up okay but they're 18 so
[ __ ] I don't think they when I'm trying
to make a plea word there were 13 you
were 20 kids they were up they were both
my size my two kids we're talking
definitely not suppose to the puerto
rican long story short now you know i'm
trying to punch this guy I'm kidding
I can't hurt him you know the kids off I
can't hurt him a cop comes running up I
get away from the kid I get away from
the case throw another kick and I wasn't
all that was 23 I didn't say secure I
didn't got sick I take that matter
regions I do what is this I think I
can't do it that wasn't all that was a
young tight skin you have prior two
weeks ago sir about three weeks here now
listen so long story short nobody gets
hurt the cop comes running up goes who's
fighting well I know but when the cop
came running up I moved and I bounced
off him and he goes who's fighting and I
go those guys grabbed my girl ran away
now here's what's great about the story
here's what the how [ __ ] up I am I'm
so angry went back and got a gun
that old bride goes gets in his car I
had an Acura white Acura all bride gets
in his car and I get a [ __ ] stick I
had an ax handle I had an axe handle I
hickory ax handle cuz I saw it in a
movie somewhere somebody shell talk
about hair cream and now I'm driving
around looking for these [ __ ] guys
because I'm gonna I'm gonna hit him as
hard as I can and in the head that's how
crazy I was never ran into all the Liam
Neeson story when he was searching for
black I know you're searching for no
that's not true
never found him for a week a week that's
how I growl moms huh
I had wrong you problems I pried stuff
you know he sell problems I get I get so
I agree injustice guy felt like they
were being rapists or something I had
they were they just gradually talking on
my foot
no no they were doing it they were doing
it to me
now I got a story about to sneeze I got
a story about fighting naked okay Jimmy
Burke who you know I know Jimmy Burke I
love Jimmy Jimmy Burke's I think it's
his well his okay his his cousin no his
his nephew he's a police officer Staten
Island they got a call when they get
there an intruder had come in and he was
he was well let me let me go they the
woman answers and she's in a row but
she's half-naked and he goes what's
going on says there's an intruder in our
house and my husband is fighting him
okay so they come running in and they
find the guy who's a big athletic guy
he's naked as the day is long and he's
got the guy in a [ __ ] guillotine
choke only who had broken in yeah and
they go let go and he goes I'm not
[ __ ] letting go not letting go this
guy cuz the guy had come in yeah with a
weapon apparently yeah and and for yeah
well so but he had him there and he said
let him go we got him and they cuff him
yeah and they he's holding on him and
when they when he let him go
the guy was blue and dead what was he
had so what that happened was they were
[ __ ] on the couch this guy who was a
rough what and what's with Jimmy's
connection so his his his I believe his
nephew I'll check with him I think it's
his nephew through them through a
marriage his his nephew was one of the
cops on this case okay come in so they
were [ __ ] on the couch a dude breaks
thinking they're not in the house breaks
the [ __ ] window and jumps into the
living room
Jesus the guys mid mid mid stroke yeah
pulls out obviously with a hard-on you
may as well you may as well get the jump
on a [ __ ] Doberman Pinscher who's
having said correct idiot correctly so
diamond dick came at the guy and the guy
grabbed his legs and he put him in the
old guillotine no [ __ ] and [ __ ]
killed him naked and hard-on while his
girl watched him and then just was like
get him honey yeah then he slew a man
that's pretty romantic
is he slew him in in his house and I
want my question is I wonder if they
finished up after that they should tell
him shut up right now tell him bro dude
Bratz teen 84 tight rope any [ __ ]
questions great movie what's up bro hey
I don't have to beat you up in the name
of Clint Eastwood dude I'm sorry I
apologize
all you got to do you're being dude
Simulink Simulink expect dude semi link
I'm dude all you got to do is send me a
link to clinics wits old movies dude I
swear to god I'm gonna close my do it
hold all right send me a link
dude I don't give a [ __ ] now listen up
this is [ __ ] theater looking right
here now where you gonna go get the [ __ ]
off me all right all right
say clinics which sucks all right okay
wrist pin [ __ ] off
smacked you do it one more [ __ ] time
and then one I'm coming at you you run
with your body and you have your wrist
dude it's right right right yeah you
can't get fight so jump outta here I'm
spindly dude how are you so spindly I
know you can
[Music]
my new shirt your new shirt
you're Cassius Clay new shirt you love
[ __ ] fighter that's so disrespectful
that you smack my face a bunch of times
I could literally see you for a salt
well I would make a [ __ ] dad this has
been a terrible podcast go to [ __ ]
events right now I've been the [ __ ]
just use don't ever wrap me with your
knuckles I had the best part I had the
best podcast here thanks guys we did it
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]